well today more than 140 teachers were
honored as they retired from the clark
county school district they have taught
more than 3 000 years combined connie
mcfarland received the lifetime
achievement award for working for 50
years half a century as an educator she
has worked in rural classrooms all the
way up to the university level mcfarland
says switching it up always kept her
wanting more
if you make changes
then you have that sense of newness of
freshness what can i bring to this
experience what can i learn from this
experience
and because of that i just always loved
where i was at the time
more than 600 teachers retired last year
from the school year on eight news now
at six we dig into some of the reasons
behind it and how teachers are working
to support each other after a turbulent
couple of years you think about a
teacher like miss mcfarland 50 years of
teaching wow and the tens of thousands
of students she positively impacted what
a way to live life she touched a lot of
lives good for her and all of those
teachers